é porque estamos produzindo
coletivamente resultados que ninguém
quer essa frase do Otto scharmer eu vi
há mais de 10 anos na reunião anual do
presente Instituto em Boston e ela tem
me acompanhado desde então porque
seguramente nenhum de nós que é os
resultados que estamos produzindo dos
Altos níveis de ansiedade e stress do
excesso de lixo nos oceanos dos
homicídios da destruição em massa da
Vida em todos os seus ecossistemas
seguramente ninguém quer seus resultados
mas por alguma razão a gente tem se
visto impotente diante desse curso da
vida como se a gente não fosse capaz de
mudá-los E aí veio a covide e nos
mostrou que assim
O que é sim possível um outro caminho e
foi absolutamente contundente também
visibilizar não só as injustiças
abissais que a gente construiu na
sociedade nos últimos anos mas também o
impacto da pegada humana sobre o planeta
todos nós vimos as fotos da Nasa todos
nós vimos a vida voltar para ambientes
antigamente tão hostis e fomos capazes
de ver que há uma alternativa
há uma alternativa que não tem no
consumo um fim em si mesmo que não tem
na produção do lucro como fim e e meta
de sucesso absoluta que não tem no
individualismo extremo um Deus a outros
caminhos e a gente precisa produzir os
urgentemente a Natura mais de 20 anos
seguia por uma criança fundadora que a
da interdependência que entende que nós
fazemos parte de um todo maior essa
ideia de interdependência nos guiou na
escolha de modelos de negócio que
produzem e distribuem valor de uma forma
de centralizada em rede
Oi e a 20 anos Talvez uma das
demonstrações mais icônicas da Natura
nesse sentido foi o lançamento da marca
ecos uma marca que olhou para que o
sistema e o bioma amazônico e tentou
pensar um modelo de negócios que fomenta
a floresta em pé
e como que a gente faz isso a gente faz
Bill prospecção de ativos na floresta
Amazônia muitas vezes guiados por
conhecimento tradicional adquirido
avaliamos a sua vocação genética
associamos esse ativo a cosmética verde
de ponta e de Vanguarda pagamos as
comunidades extrativistas pelo insumo e
a repartição de benefícios por acesso ao
patrimônio genético ou acesso ao
conhecimento tradicional e isso cria um
círculo Virtuoso de uma economia que
mantém a floresta em pé ao longo desses
anos tem sido 1.8 milhão de hectares de
florestas preservadas por essa economia
alternativa mas por mais extraordinário
que seja se resultado ele não é
suficiente assim como nenhum resultado
de uma empresa sozinha ou de uma
organização sozinha será suficiente
porque é preciso que todos nós
reconhecemos as nossas escolhas diárias
de
e os nossos hábitos a nossa forma como a
gente enxerga o mundo a que pensar em
modelos regenerativos que distribuem
valor porque só desta forma seremos
capazes de efetivamente mudar o curso da
história eu acredito que a gente é capaz
Eu acredito que a gente é sim potente
para transformar as nossas escolhas em
um mundo muito mais bonito eu queria
encerrar lendo um poema de uma poeta que
eu já deveria conhecer muito mais tempo
mas eu conheci recentemente Conceição
Evaristo que eu acho que pode nos
inspirar vamos lá
a pedra pau espinho e grade no meio do
caminho tinha uma pedra mas a usada
esperança de quem marshia Cordilheiras
triturando todas as pedras da primeira a
derradeira de quem banha a vida toda não
aguento da coragem e da luta cotidiana
faz do sumo beberagem topa pedra
Pesadelo é ali que faz parada para o
salto e não recuo não estanca os seus
sonhos lá no fundo da memória pedra pau
Espinho e grade são da Vida Desafio esse
cai nunca se perdem os seus sonhos
esparramados adubam a vida multiplicam
são motivos de viagem muito obrigada e
E aí